hablemos ahora de las unidades usuales
en estados unidos para longitud si vamos
a la escala humana la unidad de longitud
más típicamente usada en eeuu es el pie
el pie y como puedes imaginar pie o pies
si estamos hablando en plural viene de
la referencia anatómica al cuerpo humano
tenemos un pie en general tenemos dos
pies ahora no todos los pies tienen la
misma longitud pero la unidad pie es
ligeramente mayor que la longitud de la
mayoría de los pies aunque por supuesto
si hay gente cuyos pies miden un pie y
civiles en eeuu posiblemente has
escuchado que la gente mide su estatura
en pies así por ejemplo un hombre que
tiene una estatura de seis pies se
encuentra ligeramente arriba de la
estatura promedio de los hombres en eeuu
tomemos el caso de este caballero que
tenemos aquí si su estatura fuera de
seis pies ligeramente arriba de la
estatura promedio esa sería también la
longitud del
expansión de brazos que estoy dibujando
aquí si queremos medir objetos en una
escala menor al pie o si queremos medir
fracciones de pie entonces utilizaremos
la pulgada pulgada y la relación entre
pie y pulgada es que 12 pulgadas son
igual a un pie 12 pulgadas equivalen a
un pie así por ejemplo este ratón que
tenemos aquí lo podríamos medir en
pulgadas una pulgada sería bueno
dependiendo del tamaño del ratón una
pulgada sería como esto aproximadamente
la longitud de esto es una pulgada la
pulgada también se usa en conjunto con
los pies para medir la estatura de los
seres humanos pues muy pocas gentes
miden exactamente un número entero de
pies así por ejemplo mi estatura es de 5
pies 5 pies y nueve pulgadas y 9
pulgadas en ocasiones esto se denota
como 5 un apóstrofe para denotar pies y
nueve pulgadas
con dos apóstrofe es para denotar
pulgadas y puede recordar esto pues nos
estamos yendo a la siguiente escala de
medición por eso usamos dos apostrophes
ahora si queremos ir a objetos que están
a una escala mayor que el ser humano
para eso tenemos la yarda la yarda una
yarda equivale a tres pies y dado que
cada pie equivale a 12 pulgadas entonces
una yarda equivale a 36 pulgadas
esta unidad se utiliza para medir
diversas longitudes en eeuu pero la más
famosa es la que se utiliza en el fútbol
americano así es que de acuerdo al
reglamento oficial la longitud de un
campo de fútbol americano la longitud de
un campo de fútbol americano es de 100
yardas creo que aquí no puedes leer mis
números 100 yardas es la longitud de un
campo oficial de fútbol americano es
esta longitud que mide la distancia que
hay de una zona de anotación a otra
ahora para medir longitud es aún
largas usaremos la milla usaremos la
milla la milla estas unidades que hemos
mencionado se han utilizado por mucho
tiempo podemos decir que por miles de
años en particular la milla de acuerdo a
lo que pude leer era utilizada durante
el antiguo imperio romano la palabra
anilla viene de la raíz 1000 haciendo
referencia a que en esa época una milla
equivalía a mil pasos de uno de los
grandes soldados del imperio romano
actualmente una milla es igual a cinco
mil 280 pies cinco mil 280 pies ahora si
deseas calcular cuántas pulgadas hay en
una milla hay que multiplicar cinco mil
280 por 12 para darse una idea de lo que
es una milla aquí tenemos una anilla en
este mapa de nueva york y si la quieres
ubicar en la ciudad digamos en manhattan
este tramo de aquí tiene una longitud
aproximada
millán así es que si queremos medir
grandes distancias como distancias
dentro de una ciudad o distancias de una
ciudad a la otra o distancias digamos el
diámetro de la tierra o inclusive la
distancia de la tierra a la luna
en esos casos estaremos usando la anilla
comunidad de longitud por ejemplo se
sabe que la distancia de la tierra al
sol es 93 millones de millas si estamos
midiendo el perímetro de un terreno o
las dimensiones de un campo de fútbol
americano estaremos usando yardas
si queremos medir longitudes a una
escala humana o inclusive medir las
alturas de los edificios o cuestiones
similares de hecho para las dimensiones
que se requieren medir en los terrenos
utilizaremos en esos casos como unidad
de longitud los pies y si requerimos
medir fracciones de un pie u objetos que
son más pequeños de un pie vamos a
utilizar las pulgadas